[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur premier
ministre notre pays traverse une période
troublée qui alerte sur la fragilité de
notre démocratie
pourtant depuis 18 mois vous en attaque
et les fondements constitutionnels le
bicamérisme tout d'abord nous sommes au
sénat que le président de la république
a mis en cause ouvertement dans sa
lettre aux français la liberté d'aller
et venir et le droit de manifester
désormais sous une chape préfectorale
par votre loi anticasseurs vous attaquez
également depuis des mois à la liberté
de l'information avec la loi sur le
secret des affaires
puis la loi sur les faits que news qui
fragilise le travail des journalistes
la protection des sources et les
lanceurs d'alerté le président de la
république voudrait aujourd'hui créer
des structures subventionnées devant
veiller à la neutralité de l'information
au parfum de pravda ou de rtf ces
mesures ces déclarations ensemble font
système et doivent nous alerter
hier c'était une tentative de
perquisitions dans les locaux de
mediapart à laquelle nous avons assisté
inédite inquiétante parce qu'elle touche
à la protection des sources
cet événement éclaire d'un jour édifiant
votre attention particulière à la
nomination du procureur de paris et
votre refus de l'indépendance du parquet
monsieur le premier ministre votre
majorité joue un jeu dangereux mais on
ne joue pas avec les libertés publiques
le paysage démocratique qui se dessine
sous nos yeux inquiète y compris dans
les rangs de votre majorité
il suffit de voir le score du vote sur
la loi anti-casseurs monsieur le premier
ministre
quand allez vous cesser de fragiliser
nos libertés fondamentales pour vous
répondre la parole et
madame lagarde déchaumé la parole
monsieur le président mesdames
initiatrice messieurs les sénateurs une
hamasyan hatrize de la gontrie
je vous ai écoutés évidemment avec
beaucoup d'attention mais je ne partage
pas l'analyse que vous faites de ce que
vous appelez un système je reprends vos
propres mots un système portant atteinte
à la liberté d'expression et au respect
des sources
je voudrais d'abord vous dire qu'en tant
que garde des sceaux et vous le savez il
ne m'appartient pas de commenter des
procédures judiciaires
je m'y astreins de manière extrêmement
strictes précisément parce que je suis
attachée à l'indépendance de la justice
et au respect des lois et vous le savez
ces lois m'interdise d'intervenir dans
les affaires individuelles je souhaitais
ici vous le rappeler je vais donc par
rapport à la sphère que vous évoquez
vous donner quelques éléments qui ont
été rendus publics
le parquet de paris vous le savez a
ouvert une enquête préliminaire portant
sur des infractions d'atteinte à la vie
privée
deux magistrats de ce parquet se sont
donc rendus au journal mediapart pour se
faire remettre les enregistrements
sonores de conversation qui serait
intervenu entre messieurs benalla écrase
les magistrats agissait je tiens à le
préciser ici dans le cadre non coercitif
de l' enquête préliminaire et il ne
pouvait procéder à une saisie sans
l'assentiment du représentant légal de
l'entreprise de presse mediapart a dans
un premier temps refusé de remettre ces
enregistrements puis ensuite les a
donnés à la justice ce qui a permis et
ce qui permettra de faire toute la
lumière sur cette affaire
madame la sénatrice je voudrais ici vous
redire que je suis attachée comme tout
le gouvernement et à la liberté de la
presse et à la protection du secret des
sources des journalistes
car je considère que ce sont les pierres
angulaires de notre démocratie
je suis également très attaché à ce que
la justice ne fasse pas l'objet d'un
talent
ces centres qui paralyse son
fonctionnement c'est je crois aussi un
élément indispensable du fonctionnement
dans la sérénité de la justice
c'est en tout cas ma conception de la
justice celle que partagent ce
gouvernement et je puis vous assurer que
je suis tout à fait en clean et disposer
et volontaires pour continuer en ce sens
madame de la gontrie d'abord dire mon
regret que le premier ministre n'ait pas
souhaité sur un sujet qui va bien au
delà des compétences de la garde des
sceaux s'exprimer à l'instant car je ne
vous ai pas demandé de vous exprimer sur
une affaire judiciaire même si madame la
garde des sceaux ayant commis une
tribune au mois de septembre afin de
tenter que la commission d' enquête du
sénat n'auditionnent pas monsieur
benalla je pense que quand ski qu'en ce
qui concerne la séparation des pouvoirs
vous avez une conception qui est assez
variable dont conclure